I've got lots of things that,
that alarm me [inaudible] worry me and
concerned me.
And I am,
I'm a rabid optimist.
Um,
uh,
I,
I just keep seeing so many people doing
cool things.
I mean,
I met a guy,
have no idea whether this,
whether this technology is going to
prove out.
Um,
but I met a guy last summer who's
working on a kind of concrete,
uh,
cement portland cement is the basic
cement.
Portland cement is a real greenhouse gas
emitter.
I mean construction.
So,
you know,
I,
I don't know,
these numbers are going to be wrong,
but construction is 25% of greenhouse
gases and submit is 40% of construction,
something like that.
So it's a big deal.
And he is invented this cement that he
says,
I think he's calling in California
summit that has
one 10th,
again,
order of magnitude number,
um,
the,
the greenhouse gas emissions of this.
You're like,
wow.
You know,
I mean,
that's cool.
And then you hear Urbano speak,
and I've heard Bano speak to 10,000
people at my daughter's college
graduation.
And I've heard Bano speak to a group of
50,
30 something managers in a small room
and you think this is the most
charismatic man I've ever met.
And you think this is quite,
he's a rock star,
you know,
I mean,
and,
and you,
he knows you so smart and full of energy
and,
and then you meet,
um,
people involved in,
in,
in healthcare who are not getting
involved in sort of sterile debates
about,
well,
they're not out,
they're not sterile,
but,
but highly politicized debates about
the healthcare policy in the United
States.
But her saying,
if we go and apply the principles of the
Toyota production system to the
management of hospitals,
we can reduce by 90% the number of
infections from introducing a central
line and we can improve by 50% the
outcomes for people who have,
who come into emergency rooms with heart
attacks.
Do you think if we just do this,
we,
and,
and they do what,
uh,
we,
when you see this kind of,
uh,
of,
of activity,
you can't help but think
this is really cool.
I mean,
you can't help but be optimistic.
It's,
it's really exciting.
No.